Finally, we're going to talk about structural patterns.
And this is a very pragmatic pattern to discuss
honestly because it's a pattern you use if you're
ever migrating data, from relational data base management systems,
to a Hadoop system. And what you do
with this pattern, is taking advantage of the fact
that Hadoop, doesn't care what format your data is
in, which means you can take advantage of hierarchical
data, which will allow you to avoid doing
live joins and several data sets at the time
of analysis. So if you know a kind of
information you're going to want to get later you can
save a lot of time by reformatting your data. Now in order to
use this pattern, your data sources must be linked by some
foreign keys, and the data must be structured and row based,
and in fact this pattern in the book of [INAUDIBLE]
design pattern is actually they refer to as structured hierarchical pattern.